c'est déjà les fêtes pour cette enseigne
de jouets de plaisir ne pouvoir recevoir
de clients un drive ainsi qu un click
and collect ont été mises en place pour
préparer noël
on est là pour satisfaire des milliers
d'enfants en parle de noël c'est notre
notre coeur de métier c'est notre adn
c'est d'être digne de quelques week-ends
pour cela c'est une organisation reprise
du premier confinement adapté pour la
forte affluence habituelle de fin
d'année
pour nous ça a été facile parce qu'on
était déjà armé
on a l'habitude de se préparer à une
saison de jouer ce surcroît d'activité
on le connaît on anticipe donc on a
gonflé nos stocks on a compté nos
équipes on a fait un catalogue puissant
avec de nombreux drops
on tourne à 16 personnes sur notre
magasin c'est de traiter un volume de 2
200 commandes jours les clients prennent
rendez vous devant la boutique pour la
remise de leurs commandes presque en
propre avec un drive commandes ans c'est
quand même assez facile pour nous pour
aller chercher les cadeaux de noël
c'est déjà assez triste comme ça donc je
pense que pour les enfants ça c'est
quand même bien que ils ont alors joué
quand même de noël que ce soit
évidemment lors de contacts
téléphoniques et sms ou lors de remises
des produits en drive on peut dire que
malgré le port du masque
les sourires sont perceptibles et plein
de sincérité et de réciprocité ça c'est
vraiment le plaisir au quotidien
bien que vides de clientèle la vie
continue à l'intérieur du magasin
puisque les employés s'attelle également
à prendre les commandes en ligne et
préparer les livraisons à domicile donc
l'organisation à l'efap nous avons des
collaborateurs qui seront impliqués en
magasin il ramène est produit ici à
partir de là il ya un rapprochement qui
s'opère on édite un bon de livraison et
d'expédition pour mais le produit en
carton et de livraison enfin le carton
bon d'expédition et c'est parti une
organisation prévue pour sauver noël
en attendant de savoir si le magasin
pourra rouvrir début décembre